there's nothing more I can do to prepare
for this and let's go for it
I'm not convinced by how shaking my hand
is okay
if all goes well in a few hours time I
am going to be tattooing someone this is
Tash and Gaia
I'm Tash Guyer we're from Lost Fox
tattoo and we are going to be training
Tom for the next few hours do I need to
say don't try this at home because not
only is it unsafe to do this without all
the facilities we've got here we had to
go through legal and insurance and
permitting stuff to do this if you don't
have that support do not try this as for
who I'm tattooing
this is Hannah hi uh you might recognize
it from the background of a couple of
videos Han is on the production team for
this channel yes and this video was
entirely my idea I have quite a few
tattoos already and I just thought it
would be fun to see if Tom could give me
one as well so just to be clear don't do
this and if any of us aren't comfortable
at any point here we won't be doing this
with all that in mind should we try it
yeah
so hands washed I assume everything else
here is going to be sanitized first yes
all right so gloves on gloves on first
right so you've got yours down there so
I'm going up from zero to hopefully
Tattooing in one day how long would this
normally take depends how Brave your
friends are that's right
and wheels from early on
oh you can give me because the sooner
you start on real skin
it kind of accelerates it so the quicker
you get to actual human skin the better
that sounds really weird when you when
you stop like tattooing the neighborhood
cats and you start tattooing humans
that's when you start getting really
really good really fast and this is
synthetic skin then this is yeah it
feels really weird I know it's weird
it's weird
if you look closely it should have kind
of pores almost like real skin there's
still a very big difference because it
doesn't stretch in the same way that
real skin stretches right but it's a
good place to start okay this is the
machine
it's a like I said it's a rotary machine
so it's just got a little motor inside
so this doesn't look like your standard
what you'd expect I I had a picture in
my head of what a tattoo gun looked like
and that is not it yeah this one is very
streamlined this is called a pen style
so you literally just
Far Cry from the Sailor coils that you
said
for some reason that scares me a little
bit more because like oh this is not a
different thing this I feel like I'm
going to be overconfident if it's just
like hold it like a pen that's just a
glorified pencil it'll be fine
so now we're just wrapping the part that
you hold with some grip tape this is
just
to help you grip it
um and it also just secures everything
you are holding something that is
shaking and you're trying to do a very
it's a motor set yeah so yeah so the
grip tape sort of helps
swallow some of that vibration
can I hold that you can my gloves are
still still safe so yeah but so I've
just kind of gone into my normal pen
hold there is that right so how do I
need to hold this the way that I usually
hold the machine would be more like
kind of you've got a tighter grip on it
than you would a pen okay
um and making sure that you've got a lot
of like
coverage on it rather than just holding
it like a like a pencil like this when
you're writing a lot of what you do
comes from your wrist but when you're
tattooing it comes more from your elbow
straighter so when you if you hold it
like a pencil the Temptation is always
there to like like this yeah but when
you're pushing it's better to have it so
if I have sort of two fingers there and
a knuckle wrapped in there is that yeah
I mean it's there's no hard and fast
rules okay it is what feels makes you
feel more confident more in control
exactly exactly if you give the whole
bed a good spray all right
foreign
just got a massive static shock of that
yeah that happens
obviously a lot of tattoo artists will
work free hand but presumably you can
print out design and then follow the
lines along for someone like myself oh
it's actually pretty rare that you would
freehand okay I'd say in 99 of instances
you would use a stencil okay
um it will be a designs that you've kind
of drawn up beforehand and then people
will pick that design and then you'll
just have it printed out and ready to go
Okay so we've got everything clean
filmed yeah we've got the soap towels
tattoo machine ink
anything we're missing no this is all
you'll need all right and a needle
needle in the cartridge that would help
um
as soon as you do it you'll realize okay
this is all right I've got this so we'll
take them out of the casing in a minute
and have a look we can push the needle
out and see all the individual needles
inside because right now that just looks
like one thick needle yeah so now if you
have a look we'll just push the needle
up and you can see oh
I mean I can't I can just see at the
very top just a little it looks almost
like it's a serrated edge or something
yeah so that's the individual needles
yeah it has
just kind of sunk in for me that this is
like an actual like
a factory medical treatment device like
this is this is a really serious thing
that if all goes well I am going to be
piercing someone's skin with
in a few hours and that has just hit me
that's just arrived in my head are you
ready yeah yeah sure sure okay so pick
up information make getting a decent
machine make sure I point it
that way so I'm facing yep so I can see
the needle it's coming out that way and
it's going to be over here and I'm just
going to try and draw a line
that way so you want to dip into the ink
just a little bit okay and you'll see it
kind of shoot up into the cartridge
oh yeah
this fills the cartridge again I don't
know if that'll have shown up on camera
but it like bloomed yeah up so that's
now loaded and ready to go yeah so you
want to just give it a gentle wipe on
the on the paper that you've got
so that's just getting rid of a little
bit of excess that's suddenly terrifying
okay
so then you want to grab a little bit of
the Vaseline put it down onto the skin
with your little finger I'd say yeah I
need to keep that away from me yeah
so how deep you want to make contact and
then you want to go maybe a millimeter
okay lower than that
wow that
I expected more resistance
um I expected much more resistance to
that
ow
that
that felt like it was too deep I I had
felt like was it the noise yeah
sometimes the noise can be a bit
um scary at first but I don't actually
think that that did look very deep you
might be moving a bit I think there is I
think also I think the reason it's
making that noise is because there's
you're not stretching it enough so
what's happening is it's just kind of
vibrating with the machine and also
you're going very fast okay so it's sort
of bouncing along because you're pulling
so fast and then the needles okay like
this yeah
wow that was really good really
it was really really good isn't it
that felt right I don't know why well a
lot of tattooing is just feeling you can
feel when it's wrong you can feel when
it's right that's brilliant
it's really good
I mean it's not a straight line
but it's a solid line and also you
aren't a printer
you can't draw as perfectly straight
line it's not possible but that's a very
straight line
it's really rare when I do one of these
things it turns out I'm not immediately
terrible I'm not used to this if you go
too light
you can go over it again if you really
precise right yeah what happens if you
go too deep so if you go too deep
there's less that can be done because
you you can end up with a blowout and a
blowout is when too much ink enters in
the same place and doesn't have anywhere
to go so it spreads so yeah lighter is
better than too deep can I try doing a
curve I'll try and do a sine wave along
there or something yeah so with curves
you do actually want to utilize the
wrist it helps to kind of plant down and
then you can use the wrist to create a
natural curve that doesn't waver because
if you don't have anything kind of
planting you down then you are more
likely to wobble as you go around I
guess I've just got to spend a long time
making a lot of lines now yep
[Music]
that is not a circle
[Music]
you're doing it without a stencil spam
so let's talk about stencils how does
that work so it's literally just we
print it straight from our iPads to the
printer so anything that you've drawn
there will come out with stencil ink you
transfer it onto the skin and it will
just kind of like stick on transfer and
you can just Trace over it right
um so these are some stencils I've
printed out for you so I'm not tattooing
that ink in I'm still using the same ink
same needle same everything this is just
a guide and that's just yeah it's just
safe to use yeah it's a guidance
specially formulated for this exact
purpose and this exact purpose only
um obviously this is backwards at the
minute because when you cut them out
you're going to put them on this way
um and a heads up as well it's gonna be
way harder to do that okay then it will
to do um all right let's start with
let's start with top left let's start
let's start with the name yeah why not
cool it's got some straight lines it's
got a very not straight line in there so
on the skin
all right I'm gonna put this up top here
so I can stretch the skin probably so
yeah and this is the part where you
would shave the skin as well but yes
Superfluous in this instance so you just
want one little spray of that remember
yep
so just rubbing it in until it starts to
feel a little bit sticky so then you
just want to place that on making sure
not to move it around as soon through
the right place got it yeah okay
and then you're going to want to peel it
off
a little bit leaky there yeah it's it's
really hard on fake skin that would have
come out perfectly on normal all right
and
oh that was wobbly
I know exactly why it was wobbly I saw
you lift your elbow right right let's
try the oh
but
I was inspired a lot better
I should have refilled with ink before
doing that and I started too farther
right I mean it does look a little bit
like a serial killer writing the name at
this point I'll I'll take it but it's
not the it's not the straight lines I
have right at the start but practice
you okay
the seal killer line really okay
am I wrong
no entirely by the looks like you're
feeling a little bit more comfortable
with those yeah yeah I mean the straight
line is solid it's matching it and it's
stopping at that point so it doesn't
look like someone's scratching away
getting that yeah that the curve on that
too looks amazing so I think you know a
little flower with a some petals and are
you sure about this 100 sure okay I
wouldn't be doing this okay so I've
actually already got something a little
bit similar to what you're going to do
the Tash has already done for me this is
Benny and
um he's got a little flower in his mouth
so we thought we would replicate all
right
so we should just make clear this is
tattoo like very very Basics 101
simplest thing there is I'm learning the
very first step don't try this
I'm absolutely comfortable where we're
at seeing what you've done here and you
know knowing that you're going to be
doing this exact stencil like over and
over and over again I feel yeah very
very much comfortable very happy all
right so I'm
so I'm just gonna drill this over and
over again same pattern it gets in my
head yep
I don't know why I look directly at you
I realize how [ __ ] this looks but I'm
not going to take any risks with this
[Music]
put some more stencils down
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's not bad actually
[Music]
those all felt good they looked good
I mean it's the last one here I know you
just put another sheet down oh something
symbolic that felt good I'm gonna just
turn the
turn the tattoo machine off I mean of
course I'm gonna read critical of it
because I'm critical of everything like
that I can point out a dozen things
wrong with that
but we've come a long way from that
wonky one just there yeah
Han how are you feeling I think it looks
great like genuinely and you know this
this is going on my skin feeling to be
and so you know [ __ ] tattoos I've got
silly tattoos but I wouldn't put on
something on my skin that I thought in
however long I was gonna go that looks
like trash that last one you did
fantastic that looks really really good
it's not going to be perfect yeah but if
you look at some of them like this one
that one was lovely that was like the
second one I did and it's amazing but in
all of them there are bits of it where
you go that's that's remarkably good
there are bits that literally you might
want to do a little bit touching up on
but as a whole like
okay will you stay in practice all of
these and
we can just set up a separate bed and no
pressure all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after hours and many little drawings of
flowers what do you think can I do this
safely yes I think that you have nailed
the health and safety and you're really
nailing it you've really taken it all in
so Han I am confident that I can do this
without hurting you yes well beyond the
extent the tattoo is charming you
the thing is each of these lines I've
got maybe a
70 80 hit rate on each of these lines
the trouble is the design requires eight
lines the odds of me getting all of
these spot on the first time I'm doing
it on actual skin
it's not 100 at all and the fact that in
all of these designs there doesn't ever
seem to be something that's not fixable
this was what I was going to ask you two
about like how would you fix these could
you fix these all of these all of these
are definitely in a fixable so yeah okay
obviously we're going to be here we're
going to be watching and if there is
anything that you're not comfortable or
confident to touch up we can do that for
sure all right yes yes I'm happy and um
I've already set you up a station over
there it's all correctly set up
sanitized ready to go and so we're just
going to move you from this bed to that
bed
all right
I'm glad you said it not me so uh first
thing we do is infect me disinfect
thank you
I've got surgical assistance here
all right so that's
disinfected
and then
razor yep
you okay with that yep I think we
covered that three smooth arms but all
right yeah spray the stencil prep
which gets rubbed in
you're gonna have to remind me of all
the steps as we go you're doing really
well these are all the steps so far I'm
gonna place it just here yeah and then
hold it on nice and tight
make sure there's contact for all of the
design yep
that's the cleanest stencil we've had
yet okay and it looks really nice all
right so one more time are you 100 okay
with that being there yes I'll do what
you always do when you're going get a
tattoo which is you go stand have a look
in the mirror okay and just go take it
for a test drive yeah I think I think
that's me tickets for a spin around the
block
I think it looks very cute okay it's
very cute there I'm just gonna be clear
like that's that's been printed on an
inkjet printer that looks perfect yep
I'm sure I can do this safely you guys
are sure I can do this safely I'm it's
not I'm gonna do the very very best I
can I have no doubt that you will all
right so yeah
um I'm very happy so you know
let's do it let's do it yeah let's do it
okay so if I'm here
how's that yep
this tattoo feels so much more surgical
when you have three people
come back
another thing for me is realizing and
this is obvious in hindsight yeah your
skin is curved yes
okay yeah so I'm gonna so stretch the
skin like that I mean
what more can I rehearse
it's go time it's go time baby
you got this
it's gonna be okay so first thing
rustling over the whole area
about that much a little bit less yeah
so we're just gonna go
like that and see how it doesn't smudge
as well it doesn't smudge anything and
that's just visible okay so we're
stretching the skin there we're
stretching the skin there and I'm
following
probably a bad time to say my hand is
shaking
it's okay the way frequencies work when
the thing's shaking they'll cancel each
other out and it'll be perfectly smooth
science all right there's nothing more I
can do to prepare for this and let's go
for it
[Music]
all right so we're gonna fill up the ink
yep that's filled I look okay to you yep
just what exactly
have at the Forefront of your mind you
want to hover not sink in you want to go
slow
and you want to look at where you're
going yeah
I'm not convinced by how shaking my hand
is okay
how was that
[Music]
there's more wobble than I'd like
that was not that's that's
I can see where my hand shook but we got
a line I'd say dub that now to get rid
of any excess yeah
from my point of view that felt like
every other tattoo I've ever had
that wasn't more painful all right yeah
all right
it's not
perfectly inkjet printer smooth but it
is on the line I'd be a bit freaked out
yes it's on the line you are not an
inkjet printer yes you're in the wrong
career there is
yeah I'm also not running out of ink
halfway through and claiming anyway
that felt good that was so good that
felt good that was really good
wonderful I'm not looking at it that's a
solid line oh I said it was about like
80 chance on each line
so far we've got like a three out of
five we've got a I think that's about
the best you're gonna get here
let's try the other side let's try the
other side okay don't get overconfident
no calm same Pace same depth same
everything yeah
do I want to change my angle on this
follow
that felt a little fast at the start it
was a bit fast to have a little wipe and
see how it went in
it's a little bit patchy at the very
start I think I prefer to leave it that
way for a professional rather than try a
second line on that yeah
now the petals all right
five lines left
squiggle in the middle color in the
center
yeah
here we go
not sure on that one and we'll see a
little bit light on this a little bit
light let me just
it's all there though it's all there
so that is slightly smaller than the
petal design so I'm going to try to make
sure that if I'm going to make an error
it's going to be the same kind of small
error at the same kind of
the same way you know what I mean
it's okay
stretch the skin
that speed was much better that speed
was much better I'm gonna go for the
next one because I'm set up for it all
right
number four yes
foreign
happy for you to try patching it up if
you know exactly you know oh yeah you've
got that you can you that was a clear
that was like a total Miss so yeah it's
just a total mess so you can yeah I just
forgot that skin is three-dimensional
that was on me
you can do I'm going to sweep this way
around on this
excellent
I'm not sure I think I still missed that
last part that's okay because that's
where you're going to put the dot in the
middle so it's all right that's that's
now a continuous line all right okay
last line
let's go
ah sorry hun it's good it's not a
disaster but again the Skin's
three-dimensional it got away from me
let's wipe that we started so well
so I just need to
that's a lot better that felt
really good touch up okay
so the last bit is the very center and I
just need to small circle
yep
I think I think that's it
I think that's it you know what
I think that might be the best one of
the flowers that I've done yeah it's not
perfect not by a long way there's a
little bit of wobble here and there but
there's nothing in there that I know you
can't face yeah if you want to have a
quick look and then head to the mirror
very excited
that looks so good like genuinely so
good
yeah some of the lines are a bit
squiggly but like as a whole like that's
one whole ass tattoo thank you Daddy
really looks so cute I'm very very
chuffed
look at that
time
you know what now I'm not close up to it
yeah it doesn't thank him
so good
[Music]
a little bit close to me
[Music]
it's uh two weeks later we are filming
something else and uh but you might want
a quick update how's it doing huh it is
completely healed and it is looking as
good as it did when you when you did it
I think that's often a good tell is do
bits kind of fade or peel off when it's
healing love it looks fantastic